the battered brick and jagged steel look
condemned but one of London's most
iconic buildings is being given the kiss
of life in its heyday the Battersea
Power Station consumed 1 million tons of
coal a year and supplied a fifth of
London's electricity the control room
remains mostly intact the plants art
deco design was meant to appease
Londoners decommissioned in 1983
redevelopment plans have failed and at
one point there were fears that it would
have to be demolished but never write
off property in London in 2012 Malaysian
investors swooped in with grand designs
and they expect decent returns to the
total investment is expected to reach 12
and a half billion dollars in the power
station itself the two bed apartment
similar in style to this showroom will
set you back two and a half million
dollars with 4 beds going for over 6
million buyers include British rock star
sting in the neighbouring construction
property prices while still high on
quite as demanding on the wallet but the
developers say they chose to build less
prime residential opening space to the
public means in some forms it's still
the people's power station the blend of
uses is absolutely crucial and part of
that use is three and a half million
square feet of commercial space split
between retail restaurants cafes leisure
and it's this blend that might have also
helped get the development off the
ground the Nine Elms area will also see
to subway stations built the first time
London seen a new underground in over 25
years inside expect high-end shopping
and that will be a mix of best of
British meets the best of international
brands and then surrounding the power
station in the more residential
buildings more local more village
retailing you know the butcher the baker
perhaps even a candlestick maker the
group of betting that the redevelopment
of Battersea put it in the same category
as some of London's hottest addresses
it's those independent stores
in bits of London like Marilyn High
Street and shoreditch that have made
those places and that's exactly what we
want to do here out of nearly 4,000
residential properties the companies say
they've sold nearly half and that's all
off plan so is that a good or bad sign
in a London market facing falling prices
and higher taxes on pricey property we
are finding that it's only really slowed
back down to what we would consider to
be a normal market so we're still sell
it if the proposed designs come together
this desolate corner of London could
soon see tens of thousands of homeowners
and commuters travelling through here
every day tom gibson bloomberg